皆さんは物の変化
気付くことができますでしょうか
世の中は〜常に
何言ってんだ俺
マックシェイク準備しました
うま〜
シェイクってとてもバランスのいい飲み物だと思うんですよ
あのジュースみたいにがーって一気飲みもできないし
ちまちまちまちま結構飲んじゃうタイプだと思うんですけど
あのシェイクってあの固形に見えて液体なんで飲みやすいんすよ
これだけ飲んでも実はあんまりお腹膨れないんじゃないかと僕思ってまして
けどやっぱ飲むと減るじゃないですか
でもシェイクってこれ見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども
減っているかどうかってなかなか目視しづらいんですよ
このフタがちょっと曇ってるから
だからきっとそのプレイヤーは
飲んでも飲んでもどれぐらい今減ってるのかなっていうのを
なんかだいたいの重さでしか計れないんで
いまいち残りの容量がつかみづらい
今回それを利用した実験をしてみようと思います
名付けて
うん
間違いないと思います
だってわっかんないじゃないですか見た目減ってるか
僕今から仕掛けるんですけども
まず仕掛けた人がもうちゅーちゅー飲むと、シェイクを
ちゅーちゅー飲んで、ちょっとずつ減ってくわけじゃないですか
で、ちょっと減った時にどこかにこう移動させます
あと気を引かせる
どこかにこう
ばっ！！って
散らして！
その散らしてる間に僕がこっそり…
たくさんシェイクを買ってきたので
この、ターゲットのシェイクをなんかねちょっとず〜つチェイクを…
ちょっとずつシェイクをバレないように注ぎ足していくことによって
量が増えてることに気付かないというかもうちゅーちゅーちゅーちゅー吸い続けて
永遠に
永遠にシェイクを飲み続けるかもしれない
人間の基準的にシェイクＭの大きさの重さっていうのがなかなか判断しづらいので
多少減ったところでそんなにわからないと思うんですよ
多少飲んだシェイクを増やしたところでも
気付かないんじゃないかという確率はかなり高いと思われるんですよ！
えへ…
というわけで多少無茶をしてでも
シェイクを飲んでるターゲットをなんとかこう気を紛らわして
その隙に僕がシェイクをどんどん注ぎ足して
増えてることをバレずに何本飲めるのか
実験したいと、思います
ではいこう！
ういぃ〜
休憩にしますか！
たなっち）お腹減ったぁー！
休憩にしよ〜！！
たなっちシェイクのＭのストロベリーでいい？
たなっち）あ、全然いっすよー
真似するうさぎ）はじめて〜の〜チュウ〜
うさぎ）君とチュウ〜
うさぎ）I will gi↑ve you all my love〜
はっはっはっはっはっは…
うさぎ）はっはっはっはっはっはww
wwwwww
？？？）たなっち〜
たなっち）んんっ
たなっち）はい
？？？）ねぇ
メイン撮んなきゃ…
（たなっち、画面外で会話中）
なんかアプリ始めよう、たなっち
たなっち）んん？
話が分かるね
（鼓動の音）
たなっち）だってあと２回あるんですよね
うん
２８と、３１…え、３１？
土、月だよね！たしか
たなっち）２回ありゃあ優勝っすよ
今日荷物届いた？なんか
たなっち）ううん
不在票あるかちょっと見てきてもらってもいい？
たなっち）ん〜
ワンチャンあるかもしんない気がしてきた
たなっち）なんか頼んだんすか
うん
秘密の道具を
たなっち）秘密の道具を俺が
（鼓動の音）
ヘッドスパしたいな〜
たなっち）俺が一番してぇよ…
wwwww
や、あれでも療法的には良いらしいよ
実際…
？？？）たなっち〜
たなっち）はい！
髪染めてぇ〜
（たなっち、画面外で会話中）
（鼻歌）
たなっち）結構これ割とガチで…早送りですか
（インターホン）
ん？
たなっち）出ます
お願いしゃす！
俺モンストやろっかな〜
（たなっち、画面外で会話中）
（鼓動の音）
たなっち）ん！
たなっち）ちょっとトイレ行ってきます
急いでいってら！
（鼓動の音）
たなっち）もうシェイク、べちゃべちゃ！
wwうそw
たなっち）さて今日は何を仕掛けたんだぁ？
仕掛けた？？
たなっち）絶対おかしいもん！
たなっち）絶対なんか仕掛けたよ
ん〜ん？？
たなっち）俺は今日は引っかかんないっすよ
ww
たなっち）はっはっは！
っわ！！びっくりしたww
（ずぞぞぞぞぞぞぞ）
読み込みってこんなかかるもんなの
たなっち）ん？
やばくね、読み込みの時間
たなっち）どんなもんですか…
たなっち）やばっ！
たなっち）ああでも…
たなっち）スプラトゥーンより撮ってますもんね
そうだね〜
ゴミでーす
たなっち）ゴミで〜す
たなっち）これだあぁ！！！
♪ エンディング
あなた〜マックシェイクＭ〜
何本飲んだか分かってますか？
たなっち）やばっやっ！そんな飲んでないっすよ
これ全部あなたが飲んだんだぞ
たなっち）嘘だね
ほんとにw
あのー席外す度にーちまちまちまちま注ぎ足してー
ww
あなたは
４本のマックシェイクを飲んだ！
たなっち）ちぐしょおぉ！！
皆さん、結果的に言うと
え〜シェイクの中身をバレずにすり替えても
バレません！！